für viele frauen ist das eigene zuhause
ein gefährlicher ort
sie werden von ihren partnern beschimpft
erniedrigt eingeschüchtert und bedroht
sie werden psychisch und körperlich
misshandelt und sie werden auch getötet
all das in den eigenen vier wänden einen
bereich also an dem sich frauen
eigentlich sicher fühlen sollten
das sind die ergebnisse einer
untersuchung des bundeskriminalamts die
bundesfamilienministerin franziska
giffey am dienstag in berlin vorstellte
montags donnerstags und sonntags wird
eine frau in deutschland durch ihren
partner oder ex-partner ermordet es
können natürlich auch andere tage seien
aber um sich das einfach mal klar zu
machen dass wir in einem modernen
fortschrittlichen land wie deutschland
eine situation haben wo nahezu jeden
dritten tag eigentlich häufiger noch die
zahl liegt etwas unter 3 eine frau von
ihrem partner oder ex-partner getötet
wird insgesamt seien 113.000 frauen im
jahr 2017 von ihrem partner oder
ex-partner misshandelt worden so
gefallen doch nur jeder fünfte
betroffene sucht unterstützung aus
diesem grund hat das
bundesfamilienministerium nun eine
kampagne gestartet die muss machen soll
das schweigen zu brechen
dazu gibt es seit fünf jahren das
hilfetelefons gewalt gegen frauen
dass frauen rund um die uhr anonym und
kostenlos zur seite steht
die ihr glaubt doch eh keiner die
familie wird dich verstoßen
all das haben sie gesagt aber jetzt
rede ich jetzt werde ich
[Musik]
das hilfe telefon vermittelt frauen auch
an frauenhäuser in denen sie schutz
finden
der bedarf sei aber deutlich höher als
die zur verfügung stehenden plätze so
gefallen deshalb sei es wichtig das
angebot auszubauen und das bedeutet
natürlich höhere ausgaben in den
nächsten wochen werde sie versuchen und
politische überzeugungsarbeit zu leisten
um die mittel dafür zu bekommen